johnny c'était à la fois un symbole un
phare de la france est aussi un membre
de la famille de chaque français la
rock'n'roll attitude c'était une légende
johnny c'était la démesure l'idole des
jeunes et des vieux et de tout le monde
il y en a beaucoup mais c'est l'envi sa
résume très bien la vie de jeanne et en
plus le pénitencier je t'aime
on a tous quelque chose en nous de
tennessee y en a plusieurs évidemment
mais peut-être requiem pour un fou je
trouve bouleversante
[Musique]
mais je les lui aujourd'hui je passais
plus de 120 110 millions cinq cent dix
millions je crois près de 110 millions
je crois c'est incroyable
l'envié l'envié d'avoir envie que je
t'aime que je t'aime que je t'aime
justement mal à un ferrer mangez pas
français ils voient qu'on rêvait d'avoir
pour faire l'amour ou
oh moi la vie va commencer allumez le
feu marie à l'envi ça prend aux tripes
comme ça et on l'a fait 540 quand il
chante pas très beau j'abordais et avec
ses finitions conditions tu l'auras
sortie moi je garde un souvenir très
fort de son duo avec avec avec avec sa
pelle à avec lara fabian
lara fabian ont accueilli m
mallet
[Musique]
sans avocat
je t'aime allumé l'enfant que je t'aime
que je t'aime
allumez le feu je te promets le sejm et
elle aurait dérobé des ennemis soient
tous
[Musique]